Someone once told me that there was no way to justify the use of,
I could care less and we're light years to agree with that rather brash,
narrow minded view of this particular language oddity.
I have a sense repented,
so without further ado,
allow me to present a case for I could care less.
The first argument of the prosecution states saying I could care less doesn't
make sense.
Logically,
if you mean I don't care at all than it is logically incorrect to say I could
care less,
which would imply that you at least care somewhat.
In order to prove this argument,
you wouldn't have to approve that they English language must always make sense
and that there is no room in English.
Four phrases that do not make sense and that would be impossible to prove.
An idiomatic expression is by definition an expression whose meaning cannot be
inferred by the definitions of the words that make it up or in simpler terms.
An idiomatic expression is an expression that doesn't make sense literally and
English is full of them.
For example,
to pull someone's leg doesn't mean you're going to physically grab someone's leg
and pull it.
Even though the combination of the meetings of all the words in the phrase would
suggest just such an action in a native speaker of English would tell you that
to pull someone's leg means to trick or deceive someone in a playful way.
A definition that is not at all based on the definitions of the words that
comprise the phrase itself.
If someone gets cold feet before a wedding,
you don't buy them a pair of socks.
If a decision is up in the air,
you don't wait for it to Nepal.
If someone has been in your head off,
there's no need to go to a doctor to have him sew it back on again.
Languages are full of idiomatic expressions and it's precisely the wealth of
thematic expressions that in any given language then they've been so hard for
non native speakers to learn.
I submit that I could care less as an idiomatic expression like any other,
which doesn't have to make sense in order for it to be a valid way to express an
idea.
So long as the other speakers of the language understand the meaning and upset
expression,
which brings me to the second argument of the prosecution using,
I could care less to mean that you don't care at all causes confusion.
While this argument does have some validity because idiomatic expressions must
be understood by the speakers of the language and must be something that native
speakers to actually say,
I have never ever misunderstood someone when he or she says I could care less
and I submit that all the English prescriptive that's out there have never
misunderstood it as well.
It is precisely because they do understand what someone means that they're so
annoyed when someone gets it wrong.
When we speak.
We don't rely solely on the definitions of the words in a sentence and how they
relate to each other in order to extract meaning.
We use the tone of the speaker of his or her body language,
and not to mention the context of the conversation along with an internal
knowledge of the rules and exceptions of grammar and an incredible memory,
Bank of idiomatic expressions in order to understand someone's utterance.
And we generally accept that any given utterance need not be logical in order to
be understood.
And now the final argument of the prosecution,
it's wrong,
it's just wrong.
Just check out my video on prescriptive ism.
Until next time,
I couldn't care less that you can tear less.